and Trump's going to go well I think
you're ugly and everyone's gonna go
start clapping and cheering I know and
I'm I think personally I'm just past
that part and that I mean that may be
where we're at like I think we need
enough how about something like this I
think we just need more adults in the
room I think too many of us have just
let go of that uh part of ourselves in a
way did not want to confront all of the
scary mean things out there and maybe we
just need a little more of Jordan
Peterson like like stand up straight
with your shoulders back and and just
not be part of the slow descent to hell
I think that's true I'm wondering if
anyone could get into the presidency and
not get assassinated acting like Kennedy
be like the CIA I'm uncovering at all
they they know where the guy lives like
so is it more of a local adulthood that
you're trying to create well I think
DeSantis could like you know I don't
want any of these guys to get
assassinated even the ones I don't like
but you know I think that there is room
for a sane competent person